economía en france 24 nos acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de
américa latina en chile el oficialismo
está ganando esa batalla a la oposición
por ese proyecto de ley en torno a las
pensiones si santiago buenas noches pues
este jueves el tema de discusión en la
cámara alta chilena fueron los dos
proyectos para permitir otro retiro
anticipado del 10 por ciento en la
iniciativa legislativa fue rechazado y
ahora el alternativo presentado por el
gobierno irá a cámara de diputados se
lleva la delantera lo curioso es que
ambos proyectos
santiago son casi idénticos ambos
permiten que los ciudadanos retiren otro
10% de sus ahorros también coinciden en
el monto mínimo de un millón de pesos
chilenos y máximo de 43 millones es
decir unos cinco mil seiscientos dólares
las únicas diferencias son que el
proyecto del oficialismo propone que el
pago se haga en dos cuotas y no en una
que el retiro sea sujeto a un impuesto y
que no se puedan hacer reintegros lo que
llama la atención santiago es que el
gobierno saca
de este proyecto a pesar de que siempre
se ha opuesto a este retiro el
presidente incluso llevó la iniciativa
de su contraparte al tribunal
constitucional al tiempo que radicaba su
propio proyecto sólo varía entonces la
procedencia del proyecto hablemos ahora
de europa que le va a poner lupa a las
farmacéuticas en plena crisis de
pandemia si la comisión europea multó
con 72 millones de dólares a la
estadounidense cephalon y a la israelí
teva con en relación al medicamento moda
felino que es vendido bajo la marca
provigil este se usa para tratar
trastornos del sueño asociados en
concreto con la narcolepsia y otras
enfermedades neurológicas pues el
organismo dice que las empresas se
asociaron para impedir por varios años
que llegara al mercado un medicamento
genérico y más barato como lo explica
ahora la vocera de la comisión en julio
de 2005 tba introdujo su producto
genérico en reino unido a la mitad de
precio
cephalon respondió con una demanda
alegando que se había violado su patente
poco después las dos compañías se
pusieron de acuerdo para arreglar la
disputa
ansa
este no es un problema en sí mismo pero
como parte del pacto llevó a recibió
acuerdos comerciales y pagos en el franz
y según la comisión santiago los
perjudicados con todo esto fueron
finalmente los pacientes que pagaron
precios mucho más altos por su medicina
hablemos ahora de la economía mexicana
que contrario a todos los pronósticos se
está recuperando pero también la
informalidad está subiendo allí bueno se
están recuperando poco a poco las plazas
laborales perdidas durante la pandemia
pero todavía tiene casi 30 millones de
trabajadores en la informalidad que son
un 56 por ciento de la población
empleada en el tercer trimestre la
economía de este país es se recuperó un
12,1 por ciento frente a los tres meses
anteriores impulsada por la industria
principalmente pero en comparación
integran interanual o sea contra el
mismo trimestre del año pasado la
actividad económica cayó 8 6% todo esto
va a llevar a que este año en el mejor
de los casos la economía caiga 89 por
ciento según el banco central y hablemos
ahora de la cepal que le pidió a los
grandes organismos
e internacionales que ayuden a la región
de américa latina si la cepal en la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe y lo que les pidió fue
cooperación al fondo monetario
internacional y al g20 para que la
región pueda mitigar los efectos de la
crisis del coronavirus por un lado al
fondo monetario le urgió a probar giros
por 500 mil millones de dólares a los
países más afectados económicamente y al
g20 que es el grupo de países más
poderosos del mundo le pidió aliviarles
la deuda no sólo a los pobres como está
haciendo sino también a los de ingresos
medios que también han visto enormes
consecuencias por culpa de la pandemia
veamos ahora los indicadores como los
para los principales parqués
internacionales en la jornada de hoy
santiago las bolsas europeas tuvieron
una sesión con leves descensos sin la
referencia de wall street que como
sabemos no pero por el festivo del día
de acción de gracias londres bajó por
segunda sesión consecutiva por ejemplo y
en américa latina' cuarta jornada
seguida de ganancias para las bolsas de
buenos aires y de sao paulo cifra el día
para el cierre rápidamente
24 7 millones de dólares este es el
déficit que va a tener nicaragua en 2021
según el proyecto de presupuesto
aprobado hoy
muchas gracias daniela por esta
actualización del mundo económico es
todo por el momento aquí en france24
siga con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]